vous êtes par la présente conviés aux
épousailles royal du prince 10 baer de
beyrouth et de la princesse been désirez
vous êtes reprises devant nous tous par
cet homme comme épouse non
[Musique]
c'est effrayant c'est pas le moment de
commencer à cogiter sur tout ça ça se
passe comment
un jour j'arriverai à contrôler mon
destin j'ai envie de découvrir le monde
moi je voudrais savoir quand vos
maladies et vos épidémie disparaîtront
pour les remplacer par les plus mortels
depuis été ingérable
j'ai même plus de quoi si on les suit
pas si horrible
ben tu as quand même tué ce type là mais
je ne veux pas si mal que ça il faudrait
que de bonnes âmes tire ma tête vers le
haut d'ailleurs tu crois pas qu'on veut
tous à un moment de notre vie tout faire
pour essayer de partir et de découvrir
qui on est vraiment quoi je crois que je
suis une bonne louche r je vends des
animaux de compagnie
ballot
c'est bizarre ce que je ressorte n'ai
aucune envie de me bourrer la gueule ce
que j'espère
très mauvaise idée qu'est ce que la
demanderesse laisse tomber j'ai compris
je suis vraiment fier de toi
non monsieur fox et moi je suis un mec
souvenez vous que le seul truc efficace
pour pas se laisser entraîner vers la
cascade c'est de nager à contre-courant
en d'accord t'as du courage et tu sais
que si tu crois en toi rien ne pourrait
arrêter
[Musique]